[Música]
probablemente todos reconozcamos estos
sonidos
[Aplausos]
el pasado 19 de septiembre fuimos parte
de una de las muestras más grandes de
solidaridad que han tenido lugar en el
país cientos de casas y edificios se
derrumbaron a causa del sismo y 7.1
grados que nos sorprendió qué pasó con
todas esas construcciones que
considerábamos indestructibles porque se
sepultaron los sueños de todas las
personas que vivían en esas casas la
constitución política de los estados
unidos mexicanos establece en su
artículo cuarto que toda familia tiene
derecho a disfrutar de una vivienda
digna y decorosa la realidad es que la
mayoría de las familias mexicanas se
encuentran muy lejos de ver satisfecho
este derecho en méxico tenemos una
situación social muy complicada un país
que aprende día con día y año con año lo
complicado que es vivir con menos de
tres salarios mínimos mensuales en un 43
por ciento de su población esta falta de
ingresos representa la principal
dificultad para acceder a uno de los
bienes primordiales más necesarios la
casa
en méxico más de 6 millones de familias
no cuentan con un techo entre los
afortunados que tenemos un hogar el 65%
representa una casa auto construida esta
cifra me pone a pensar la verdadera
razón por la cual me dedico a esto
cambiar la manera de vivir de las
personas a través del espacio construido
pero cómo puedo hacerlo si la mayoría de
las personas auto construyen su propia
casa
la identidad en nuestro país puede
representarse fácilmente con una imagen
como ésta
para mí esas cuatro varillas apuntando
al cielo siempre han tenido un fondo
azul nublado por las condiciones
cambiantes de la sociedad mexicana
esas cuatro varillas apuntando al cielo
materializan la realidad de un país en
constante crecimiento un país en donde
los sueños de las personas se encuentran
estancados
y las personas se encuentran en una
dificultad para acceder aún a un hogar
digno esta dificultad no se ve
satisfecha ni siquiera por los
desarrollos del infonavit la verdadera
razón es que la autoconstrucción es un
problema es una necesidad que aumenta al
mismo ritmo que crece nuestra población
la autoconstrucción en américa latina'
como concepto se remonta hasta la década
de los años 50 manteniendo como eje
central la inclusión de las familias
dentro del proceso de construcción y
solución de su vivienda es decir la
autoconstrucción se define como el
proceso en el cual una familia gestiona
produce y mejora la autoconstrucción de
su vivienda
esta es otra imagen que seguro todos
reconocemos
paisajes desolados construidos en blog
de concreto gris con lo que parecería
ser una imagen una casa construida sobre
otra esta imagen no es más que la
realidad de un méxico en el que vivimos
un méxico en el que hasta los niños
participan en la construcción de su
propia casa
abraham cruzvillegas es un artista
mexicano que vivió de primera mano la
autoconstrucción de su casa cuando era
joven y para él la autoconstrucción es
una herramienta metodológica del caos el
trabajo abraham aborda el tema con
diversas piezas que han servido para
generar una concientización y un diálogo
sobre el tema lo que me lleva a
visualizar mi trabajo como una
herramienta para generar una discusión
proactiva y poder hacer de la
autoconstrucción asistida un detonador
social las primeras piezas que
materializan esta idea son parte de una
serie titulada esperanza en construcción
la cual busca poner sobre la mesa el
tema tan importante que son las varillas
de la esperanza
para mí las varias representan muchas
cosas la falta de recursos la falta de
conocimientos técnicos para la
autoconstrucción pero sobre todo que los
sueños de las personas se encuentran
todavía en obra
en el tamaño de las varillas en los
castillos en el material en el desgaste
se materializan todos estos conceptos
sobre la autoconstrucción la idea
general de estas piezas es poner a la
vista que las varillas todavía siguen
siendo parte del paisaje urbano y tratar
de generar un diálogo que encuentre la
solución o que pongan la
autoconstrucción asistida como la
solución principal para este problema
si bien no podremos detener este
fenómeno vamos a hacer que sus bases
sean sólidas como el acero
estoy seguro que la mayoría de las
personas en esta sala no construyen su
propia casa con sus propias manos
de algo también estoy seguro todos aquí
tenemos sueños sueños como los de
cualquier otra persona encontrar un buen
trabajo encontrar el amor formar una
familia y tener un hogar cuatro sólidas
varillas estas varillas representan
entonces los sueños de todas las
personas que se ven en la necesidad de
auto construir
la importancia de concientizar a la
gente que auto construye de hacerlo
correctamente y a los que no que tenemos
un deber con nuestra sociedad encuentra
el lugar en un llamado en un espacio
llamado el pabellón de la esperanza
este espacio busca ser un lugar en donde
la gente pueda acercarse y encontrar las
herramientas para convertir a la
autoconstrucción asistida en un
detonador social busca entonces un lugar
en donde la gente pueda acercarse
preguntar dialogar discutir y salir de
ahí con todas las herramientas
necesarias para que entonces la
producción de su vivienda se ha hecho de
manera correcta
aun cuando todo esto esté cumplido
podrán quedar las varillas de la
esperanza mirando al cielo con la
convicción de que todos los sueños de
los mexicanos se cumplirán
y como dice la constitución
cada familia puedas vivir en una
vivienda digna y decorosa muchas gracias
[Aplausos]